you guys good to go chin yeah chin you
dirty and he dirty hey just not rocking
brian finally got a uh a wig and his
teeth fixed uh-huh and he's on trd
yeah
maybe a lot younger dude maybe a little
bit more than trt we don't know who
knows
[Laughter]
hey i'm not judging there are actually a
lot of guys out there who do like uh
like i'm on a drawl it's prescribed by a
doctor well sounds good yeah
no doctors prescribe that [ __ ] they will
but i mean there's no legitimacy unless
you have like you know [ __ ]
uh super low red blood cell yeah
something like that yeah brian is
missing today because his uh baby is
supposed to come any second any second
he thought it was gonna be last night
and then you know kids decide when they
want to come out they do what they want
to do so he's at cedars just hanging out
yeah it's a long hanging long hang like
dude just do c-section
because then you don't have to
you don't what if she don't want to do
that she can do it
is she going to do it
it's so weird like you can do c-section
and then the kid's hair man why do
people do not want to do c-section
because the post that scar post-op the
scar the post like the recovery's a
beast yeah think about that that's car's
intent well think about they cut into
your stomach like
your abs they gotta take out like your
organs and [ __ ]
it's amazing you just got a bucket i
didn't realize how major it was i saw my
girl the doctor was like unless you're
ready for this don't look over the the
curtain i'm like yep say less but then
they left like a little hole open little
sneak peek
oh my god oh god that's a major [ __ ]
i mean the most but your emotions are
high so you're not gonna know it's like
this is a nightmare yeah more of a
nightmare it's scary man brian's going
through it right now but my thing is
when girls like they're they're in labor
for like
40 hours or whatever yeah they do the
c-section it's like you wasted all this
[ __ ]
you just knocked it out of the way right
and then also then doctor's like well
like older doctors should be like what's
good for the babies come out natural
through the vaginal wall because there's
like a mucus or something that helps
with their system or whatever it's
healthy for the baby shut up right how
much can it really be i mean what are
the tests on that like what is the
percentage and then also you gotta worry
about the kid's head comes out like a
cone head because the guess goes
that's why the skull is like flexible so
they can get through the canal there
yeah well who's talking about this
recently where it's like you know a baby
deer pops out and within two hours it's
prancing along
babies are helpless because yes they
have to throw into their heads hey yo
why do some of those babies have like
the helmets on it is that just shape the
head yeah it's because they're yeah
their heads uh dis formed and like the
they're the if you look at a skull
there's like all these lines in it yeah
yeah it's for it to form so it can get
you know now a question you know i don't
know anything about pregnancy yeah twice
hopefully um do they like um
you know lube
oh yeah do they lose oh
yeah
that's a good question i i just didn't
know because i mean it's like yeah you
don't want to just go because regina is
a self-lubricating instrument but you
know what that's what i'm saying you
know whatever that that's a lot of lube
you know what i didn't that's a lot i
didn't i didn't see that part well but
she sees what you would assume
but not for both of them right both of
them oh you want to see both of
i would not trust anything that has been
said so far about childbirth
from your family yeah based off of what
i know your youngest brother is what
like uh he is 11 turning 12.
how old was your mom when she had him um
in her late 30s okay okay too bad you're
in the 40s you're talking peanut butter
falcon kids you feel me no
all the odds
is because of old sperm not old eggs
it's all in the woman really yeah look
that up jim it's on the woman yeah the
odds of having a baby with downs like i
think it goes up significantly after 35
you start getting the 40s
then you got love on the spectrum yeah
that's why a lot of women will freeze
their eggs when they're young yes would
you say cat a lot of women will uh
freeze eggs while they're in their 20s
and 30s because yeah i don't know what
yeah
pay that rent
chances on child density increase over
time the risk is about one to one
hundred and twelve hundred
uh you can see the age 25 it's about 1
in 100 for women concedes at age 40. one
in 100 look at those odds one in 100
dude that's rough so it's not the dudes
and do you know any families that have
gone through like multiple rounds of in
vitro fertilization and it's like i'll
use it i haven't gotten it and it's like
i mean it's like ten thousand yeah right
it's very expensive yeah but also when
you see celebrities like have you
noticed like so many celebrities the
trend of having twins that's in vitro oh
yeah because they want they just want to
get pregnant once and then yeah they
want two kids so they they do that
yeah through the twin things twins
comes to mind they the in vitro you can
do it really sometimes that in vitro
like it's not a science like they put
all these eggs and they're hoping
they're not gonna dice with it sometimes
you get triplets sometimes right it can
happen spontaneously it's not or you'd
be like octomom
remember her you heard that probably her
belly wasn't insane dude or what her
octomom's belly was insane with the
[ __ ] i didn't see it oh no i just i
just noticed
look at that belly
didn't she do porn
i think there was something along those
lines yeah
i mean that i mean that's how insane
that looks photoshopped that's
photoshopped
that's real yeah don't worry about that
there's so many kids in there absolute
alien babies there's eight so many kids
in there yeah eight babies
south african gives birth to ten it's
nuts dude yeah do ten kids i want kids
with ten
ten what's the most you want to have i
would love four minutes three four it's
cool four's good four's manageable four
you don't have to buy a [ __ ] van to
get around in
yeah yeah you can still use your uh
it's tough well tiger but yeah tiger be
fine because i think kicking right in
the front if he's over 60 pounds yeah
and you have a booster seat and then you
got to turn off the air bag the thing
that [ __ ] up kids if they ran the front
is are the airbags yeah that that that
is what kills them
yeah okay it's intense dude yeah
because the airbags like uh
if you've ever like underneath the
carpet you know the bottom of a carpet
yeah that's the material
oh and then it's hard it's all scratched
you know yeah yeah it's scratching it's
like it's very rough it's not like a
soft material and then they're like this
thing because i haven't thought about
that
out of it no dude they're [ __ ]
intense right but it has to be
instantaneous anything less than yes
this extreme acceleration
to to full
inflation just wouldn't work you can't
like
it has to be boom
yeah there goes octomom turned to porn
after
oh johnny k plus eight that's the other
couple yeah they got a divorce though
they done they've been done
they don't been done they've been done
she had i remember she had the hair
it was like uh johnny kate yeah and he
was somewhat he was some asian right was
he's filipino i think half filipino i'm
not sure her kids are [ __ ] cute yeah
they had does she have a reality show no
no no she's just they just she had she
just had kids and they did porn back in
the day
wait fourteen kids fourteen kids she had
more kids before the oh god before the
eight yeah she didn't realize she had
that many though the forty the fifth hey
where's baby daddy at
he dipped out
i think so and all eight of them kids
said she said she said i didn't want to
do porn i've been celibate before i
can't count how many years so it was
cheap self-pleasure video which is still
porn i hit rock bottom oh so she wasn't
getting like railed on like yeah big
black hole she was just doing like
masturbating yeah for eight minutes i
said i still sold my soul to the devil
this is before all that
the porn uh partake in porn led to her
doing stripping on stage she stopped
when her ten-year-old daughter found out
uh she's playing with a stripper high
heels that'll do it yeah yeah that'll
make you go ugh that'd do it's a nice
story though right and i just couldn't
do it she picked up the high heels and i
broke i mean as long as
as long as she's good now yeah i think
she's good
yeah
but baby daddy never
there's no nothing on the
homie god who leaves 10 kids that's what
i'm saying
that's [ __ ]
200 thousand followers look down let's
see what she's doing
oh look at this oh
oh wow they're all older i bet it's so
[ __ ] fun and that is so cute
and it's just hitting me they're all the
same age obviously like i'm like oh all
the kids in that they're not just like
sort of things like the far right where
all the kids are sitting down
that's the sweetest just a squad i know
so fun army dogs
it's gonna be chaos in that house
it's got it but then i assume the other
five are older so they're gonna help out
she probably because the baby daddy
ain't around she probably gets a lot of
help from the government i would assume
uh if she has a job
yeah even if she has a job yeah really
there's a lot of stuff i think uh single
mothers uh can do that's cool to get
help yeah
yeah she's not a bad looking lady either
god you have to be a real
[ __ ] maverick to
hook up with her though
you'll be a real
i got 14 kids
and i see you headed off there's
chemistry and you're the step dad to 15
kids yeah
you just need to step up dude i wouldn't
imagine she has a lot of dudes coming in
and out of her life because that means
well not because think about it because
you gotta she got so many kids and it's
like if the kids she don't want her kids
to get attached that easy probably i
would assume i don't know her but two
kids is a full-time gig yeah 15. my
sister got six yeah that's so many
that's so mean i can't remember but how
did you do with guys because i just
wanted to say this
well there's this idea in the manosphere
like
like dating advice channels would be
like don't [ __ ] with a single mom like
or don't you know when i was
serious like unless you want to take on
that responsibility because there's so
many pitfalls of like you want to come
into a place where you might have
responsibility and no authority like you
got to raise these no no yeah yeah no i
think she's a nut
you know oh you're not cool
i mean we talk here and we rarely rarely
talk but she uh i mean same same baby
daddy you know oh wow yeah she's great
she's a full-time mom
uh yeah you have i mean
cause you think about daycare like you
weigh the pros and cons of daycare to
you having a job it's actually working
you're working here that makes sense
yeah yeah because then you're working to
pay it it evens out like they they
nullify each other because let's say
you're making 40 grand a year 50 grand a
year at starbucks right like you're at
that's how much the babysitting comes
yeah
she does so expensive she does get help
from like the government and stuff like
that yeah you know kyle would you have
stayed with your girl if she had four
kids you ain't ready to be a step dad
dude yeah if you don't wear a beanie
like that and be ready for stuff well
you dated a girl with four kids no i'm
saying he has a new girl i'm saying
would you have still signed up for if
she had five kids
she had three dogs i probably wouldn't
sign up uh yeah
wow really
i could be a step daddy i wasn't mine
really she spell be a good dad yeah you
would be like
i know when i worked at the daycare run
they love me i read them books all the
time and [ __ ] yeah
with kids and every day every time that
every time the parents would drop them
all the kids would just run up to me
could you do it mark could you get with
a girl if she had let's say two kids
you're oh you like kids i do like yeah
and i've worked with you on a tutor and
i know kids always like me but here's
the thing i'm just gauging it off of
like when i hang out with my nieces and
nephew i see how exhausting it is you
know what i mean like to do it full time
but like a 24-hour responsibility where
you're living with them it's a lot to
make the right decision all the time
about parenting you're not ready for it
huh i mean i wouldn't seek it out like
like i know and that's fair because that
sucked because
i worked i worked with kids as a teeter
a tutor a teeter-totter as a tutor a
teacher a coach etc
and i remember actually i used to be a
substitute teacher all around la and i
would just accept like they call you
like hey do you want to do this age this
that age this school whatever you know
teach physics teach math whatever yeah i
wouldn't care the only things i started
to turn down were kindergarten i went
there once and you realize it's the
hardest thing to do yeah because you're
stepping into this because like if you
get a class full of high school seniors
for example you can be like all right
watching the dvd i'm taking roll like
we're chilling you can talk to me like
yeah it's super relaxed with
kindergarten you have to replace every
single movement and schedule and
mannerism of the head teacher or it's
chaos like i remember coming in it was
like um
you know i'm just like reading the
instructions like all right so we're
doing uh we're doing the story time in
the circle and some kiddo back that's
not how the teacher does it and like
within 30 seconds oh it's like like a
kid's crawling off their spot and like
one glue yeah yeah like so i was like oh
my god it's like that actually makes
sense because you know kids i feel like
kids that you you're tigers that age
like they have to have like yeah that's
what's going to get that advice
yeah this is the thing i bet you don't
do well every sunday he's probably like
cars
he knows yeah it has to be a schedule
kids need structure i would just say
though that i that i experience
difficulties so i don't like other
people i'm like if you've never worked
with kids you're like oh my god it would
be so amazing to be a dad i'm like have
you ever like spent a day with kids
before yeah so entirely i know i would
like it and i would like the challenge
of it but the thing that sticks out in
my mind is you know
it is kind of like you know adopting
kids where i'd like to think oh yeah go
adopt kids yeah you want your own flesh
and blood you do want your own
words and also a statement that comes up
is the responsibility without the
authority unless the the woman is
willing to give you like the authority
to like discipline them and make
decisions which is oh you know
so are you going to become like an atm
to just be like paying for everything
and the kids disrespect you and say
you're not my real dad the best the best
is on 90 day fiance there's this dorky
white guy like
uber dork let's take a little break from
chatting with the boys backflip lacy and
mark the body harley
because if you want to look like mark
harley man or chappelle lacey boy's
getting in shape man he is man a lot of
y'all had new year's resolutions you're
looking for a good workout you want to
make 20 22 your best workout you want to
get in shape that's where my friends at
fight camp bring you the best workout in
the world right to your crib and they
make it really fun learn to box and
kickbox from home with access to
world-class programming elite trainers
premium equipment smart technology that
turns your work out into one hell of an
experience thousands of classes quick
workouts all right you don't have to be
a pro to jump into this fight camp you
don't man you have full body workouts uh
listen boxing requires a lot of focus so
you're working your brain we got the
full package for you fight camp comes
with all the gear you need all right all
the gear to start boxing from your home
including a freestanding punching bag
boxing gloves quick hand wraps smart
punch trackers takes up less space than
you think if you have enough room to do
a push-up you have enough room for fight
camp whole squad can get involved the
whole family the whole family man we got
something for everybody now's the best
time to get your fight camp take
advantage of their holiday deal going on
right now if you purchase this month you
get an additional pair of gloves for
free just go to joinfightcamp.com
fighter to get additional pair of gloves
for free go to
joinfightcamp.com fighter join
fightcamp.com fighter
new year new resolution so many
americans are resolving to save a little
more money this year
than they did in 2021 2021 was tough for
a lot of people
luckily there's the zebra that make it
easy to save hundreds on car and home
insurance in minutes the zebra what do
they do glad you asked the zebra
compares car and home codes from every
major insurance company side by side
giving you all the facts you need to
make the right decision it's the fast
way to find the right coverage in the
right place all right all from a
provider you can trust in fact the zebra
saves people an average of 922 bucks a
year on car and home insurance combined
plus
all it takes is five minutes save time
and money in minutes get your free quote
today by going to
the special url the zebra.com slash
fighter show your support for the final
kids show man that's the zebra.com
fighter
there's this dorky white guy like
uber dork and this girl's from i think
colombia i forget somewhere venezuela or
something like that and i'd called it
from day one i told my girl like she
runs with a rough crown man she has like
four kids she has tattoos on her stomach
like oh she's real rough looking like
this girl don't [ __ ] around is it her no
that's not her
that's not her
his wife's super bad but that's not her
it might be nine day fiance the other
way because he had to go to
her uh country
and you find out like she's just kind of
she's not hustling them but he's been
paying for the kids and send her money
and stuff like that then he gets there
and they finally hook up and she speaks
when i say zero english i mean [ __ ]
that is wrong zero english yeah nope
that's the lesbian yeah you're the new
spider the
atm just typed in tattoos yeah so so he
gets so he gets there and they hook up
on the the first night yeah and they're
like well how was it he's like
best night of my life like you're
working for him yeah and then i asked
her and she's like it's whatever oh
she's just like you know but it is a
different you can tell she's like i'm
just doing this to get money oh yeah
really different category and then she
picks up is that he goes to the bathroom
he's i'm taking a shower she's like okay
and she has no idea what he says because
she doesn't understand english and then
she picks up his ender and she's like
ugh who would wear these right [ __ ] yeah
and this is the recent season yeah but
that's a lot of relationships oh yeah so
so this guy uh got with this girl she's
she's not a she's a small person but
different
i don't know like her legs are really
messed up they've been friends for years
and finally comes out there and even
he's like listen man we've been friends
for like 13 years and
he's like now that i'm with her in
person he's like i don't realize how
much work it is yeah like because oh
standard hotel it's a nightmare for
right and then he has like she can carry
her everywhere yeah
no everything would be a like you can't
get a drink is it her
nope
that's him there we go mike i know the
other guy was like 34 my ass
dude he said uber dork
oh you're talking about [ __ ] yellow
bastard from sin city
so she has tats like on her stomach like
your thighs up her ass then on the most
recent episode
he was like trying to talk about her
exes and she's like yeah i dated a
sicario before like that that's my guy
oh yeah dude she's wait david what a
sicario like uh oh yeah yeah
cartel really that was her baby daddy
she's an alpha widow yeah man no he's i
don't think he's dead
he's dead i mean it's a term does the
term people use like if a girl has had
like an alpha male in their past that's
like left like you're going to be the
dude who's like always trying to fill
his shoes
yeah
i mean yeah he's not feeling that
sicario
oh dude he looks like he's dressing up
in a halloween costume to be a dork yeah
you know like he looks like he's like do
you like my costume he looks like yellow
bastard from cincinnati
oh that guy yes
yellow bastard looks like he could [ __ ]
better than that guy though for sure i
agree 100 yeah he was a pedophile he's
disgusting
oh yeah disgusting oh my god that's a
great movie
but yeah the dynamic there is a
nightmare she's got like four kids
four kids and he like he wants more kids
and then again she doesn't speak english
so he doesn't know that when oh yeah
she's colombian that when uh she had the
four kids she'd want more kids so she
had her tubes like burnt so she could
never have kids he doesn't
get burnt yeah
it has to be some colombian [ __ ]
yeah that's [ __ ] insane yeah we
[ __ ] up a knot so we just singed it
dude and then this [ __ ]
ella holler justin this big girl
boise boo this big girl ella
she's obsessed with asian dudes so she
got herself a little asian twink here
damn and
he he he lives in china
but because the covet protocol stuff
it's tough for him to get over there and
then he has a kid named stoney and he
doesn't want to leave the kid he's the
provider so he's gonna quit his job to
deal with this big [ __ ] but the thing
is
the thing is is uh he's constantly
trying to get her on a diet it's
fantastic oh really he's like dude and
then he's talking to his mom and she's
like well that's americans like they
overeat it's what they do oh interesting
yeah they're like and then she's like
you're gonna miss the food because over
there they just eat junk that's why your
wife looks like that right yeah yeah and
his friend's like aren't you worried
like when you guys hook up for the first
time she's gonna crush you and they're
like not like making jokes they're like
serious health concerns yeah
has she has she been working out and
stuff doing the diet yeah she tried
working out they show her in the gym
she's like a bet she had like
she's not like playing fitness and she's
just on the bench like doing like leg
extensions hey but that's more than most
some people sit at home still start
somewhere yeah i don't think that's
losing weight
here's that's a stereotype that we don't
usually see is like we'll see the black
dude with the big fat white girl right
yeah never seen the smaller you've never
seen the this one
yeah
um so wait how did they pair them up i
don't know the show too well they don't
pair them up they they got they
connected online somehow and then
you know motions fly and [ __ ]
they there's a connection then they've
been facetiming for [ __ ] years and
finally 90 they have 90 days he'll come
to america he has 90 days to get married
to propose to her 90 days to hit it
wrong but they have to hit but like they
could they could opt out if they want
oh yeah you did like 2 and 24. now this
guy looks like he's good looking and in
shape is that calling i know right i was
going to say that brian
they got the same shirt yeah but they
can back out it's not like a strict
thing like they can you know they could
be like this guy's terrible this isn't
like a like a blind date type of thing
no it's not like married at first sight
they can back out are there often age
discrepancies like this yeah
not this bad they like each other they
[ __ ] with each other i've never seen
them i don't know what [ __ ] show that
is
they might have been cut from her name
her name mahogany dog could you well
ben a former pastor and addict could you
scroll up a little bit uh in a strict
conservative leadership broke free from
confinement in his marriage and he
struggled to find his way forward oh so
now he's out getting all that young
[ __ ]
eventually found work as a model
he caught her eye after he's featured in
a fitness magazine her faithful dm lived
in intense text and relationship
bonded by similar religious views they
fell in love began to make plans to meet
in person despite a 28-year difference
ben's friend's family see countless red
flags
yeah i wonder what those red flags are
they've never videoed each other besides
that they've never watched a huge red
flag they've never video chatted
gotta hit them hey you you can still get
scammed on a video chat this guy's
probably getting scared there's like
something that's why they're not the
show i've never seen them they're not on
the show i bet that that was fake oh
scroll up chin because the
there's another great dynamic it's my
favorite one keep going chin
they're the fact chick and the chinese
dude the cartel
they're this black girl with big titties
and then he's in the middle east that
guy's
super dorky and his girl's a [ __ ]
smoke show but she's so jealous
she's so bad
that's always weird this my favorite
what is this kim who's 50 and then soja
boy who's 32 from nigeria
not soldier boy yeah so
boy this one is fantastic oh this is
your favorite one oh dude
she goes to nigeria so she started off
just as a super fan like of his fan club
she he flies her like super fan of him
yes huge fan and so then
scam yeah so then finally they start
like hit it off so she flies out to his
uh first like video like this video
but there's chicks there and she's
getting like all defensive and then his
friend like his entourage like he's
trying to make it you know
his entourage
as soon as she gets off the plane like
what's up super fan she's all don't
[ __ ] call me super fat i'm not a
super fan like that then what are you
yeah she's like i'm a friend like be a
super fan yeah yeah
let's be real
it's so weird so she she's icing or
anything is he a rapper
uh like just musical artists music like
reggae you know
okay okay you know it's what have you
listened to it yeah is it good it's it's
not bad you know i don't know if he's
going to make it but she
probably not how do you engage in
african music
she gets off the plane she's like i i
gotta ice my ankles because my feet
swell when i fly and i don't want my
ankles be bigger than my titties or butt
so she's like icing her ankles so then
when she got off the plane yeah so then
they meet up for the first time she's
like crying or whatever but then his
like management like gets up they're
trying to tell him like it's a bad look
dude like she's 50 and she's very
attractive like people think you're
gonna be with hot chicks yeah so there's
some huge uh artists in africa there's
like some badass african artist who
wants to collab with them yeah so he
meets with her and she's like a dime
piece yeah but he brings her old ass and
she's all she's like i'm just gonna
leave clearly you guys have chemistry
wait yeah
yeah
how old is she 50.
that's such a weird thing i mean to jump
into you like this dude's a star in
nigeria or whatever i mean he's just
young good-looking but he [ __ ]
unknown to any degree in no you can tell
like they've never met in person before
and she gets there and they have they're
staying in the same hotel but he makes
her stay in her own hotel room so it's
like
[Laughter]
clearly he's not into it but i've seen
that a few times with this like the
young good-looking african dude and like
oh yeah oh yeah
you see what's going on yeah he's just
trying to see how stella got a groove
he's trying to get that green card yeah
that's what's happening here let's see
clara's day as soon as he gets here he's
gonna piece the [ __ ] out and try and get
an empty
yeah well hopefully he makes it man the
second dude imagine that's your mom
though imagine your mom yeah and you'd
be like she's like i'm telling you i'm
headed to [ __ ] tanzania please don't
to be in the to watch my man in a rap
video like mom what like don't do it
yeah but there'd be no getting your
mom's 50 and she's like icing her ankles
i want to see this artist he's trying to
collab with
oh she's bad she's batty
she's pretty famous out there too
and she's a nigerian nigerian musician
as well yeah i graduated from fan of
potential girlfriend like she's on like
a uh
he's trying to figure out if there's
potential there yeah drake once said i
never get attracted to the fans because
the eager beaver could be the rise of
the damn oh okay i remember that one and
he's done this before this is his second
one oh he's been on this you've been on
before oh and he had no he had another
card
yeah for sure
you sure that woman 50 well no that that
was his first one and she has to be a
little over 50 okay but that didn't work
out for obvious reasons you know they
actually got married though yep that was
his first one damn they got married in
africa though they didn't come back here
also soulja boy should we change the
name if you're dreaming
we're kind of all set here dude
as far as the uh it's like being like
what's your stage name chris brown we
have one here yeah we already got engine
optimization
not the best
yeah show's fascinating though
what was it the that show he's just just
just like this okay
[ __ ] what's what [ __ ] what oh he's
arguing right now i'm so out of that
world mark scared me i was like wait i
know right am i speaking english
he's like what shows
mark's
for 20 happiness
come on bro you scared the [ __ ] out of
me i was like
right there
yeah we finally have dementia
wait what show are you
documented on the [ __ ]
go through the whole thing again turns
out d3 football cte
it got you it doesn't matter
level of play
do you have fun last night mark that was
an amazing show and i wanted a good show
in l.a man dude and [ __ ] you didn't
you didn't come to the last british shot
my friends
no because i was i'm still sick kind of
you know but like back then i was like
just getting it but last night last
night it was followed okay yeah annie
letterman a couple comics to open ate
[ __ ] and i was like actually sit in the
room like oh this might be not good
because it's a tough it's tough with
like those developmental spots like
those comics and they don't have a ton
of stage time and then you got a cold
open and then people clearly aren't
there to see them they're there for jim
gaffney
it was rough so it's an away game to the
floor
brendan oh sorry annie letterman brian
monarch david spade jim gaffigan and you
followed them yep all right darnell
rawlings j fair yeah yeah well i'm
saying you you follow david spain and
jimmy afghanistan which is a tough spot
you came out and crushed it oh thank you
sir yeah and that was fun it was it was
a [ __ ] phenomenal lineup like david
spade well first of all how great is
david what's my favorite he's amazing
and all his jokes he's like he just
speaks the whole time like this and just
yeah and he's like whatever yeah
it's literally like you're just going up
there talking yeah yeah i missed it did
you see the show the lights
yeah i love that [ __ ] show and when i
do that show like you see david spain
obviously on saturday live you guys
start there and
his you know best friends with [ __ ]
chris farley and sandler and stuff like
that you assume he's talented yeah then
when you go on that show and you see
like the monologue yes do just like the
improv yes do with the the kind of the
panel of comics yeah and i remember
sitting there watching like holy [ __ ]
usually i'll watch stuff
and i'll be like i could do this i watch
online i can't do that i remember
yeah you don't realize how talented do
you see him in person like holy we were
talking about someone uh that's saturday
night live yeah we're talking about
martin short
oh yeah yeah you and i were talking
about how like he's just
quickly [ __ ] another one of those
guys [ __ ]
monster yeah monster yeah that was a
phenomenal show and then gaff again one
of my favorites it's amazing what i mean
we're talking about this before but the
um like he takes an anecdote from i
don't want to give away his material i'm
not going to but like you just talked
about like regular mundane [ __ ] like
nobody spells for 30 minutes or like
standing in line yeah just you're like
holy [ __ ] yeah and i'm just like
and i knew going in i'm like i wonder
what he's because i saw that he was
performing like he had an hour i don't
know if he did a full like 55 minutes or
whatever but he you know he was on there
he was up there for a while did he oh
did he close it out no no he did brandon
came out right now 20 minutes oh sorry
so i'll say like
if one of the first comics came out
after jim gaffigan did it would have
been like yeah super awesome yeah yeah
brandon kept up the energy he's such a
beast and jay pharaoh's a i've never
seen jay fair before he's yeah he's dude
he's because you've never seen him on
snl he's all his uh you know he's doing
a bomb or whatever so it's like oh here
we go um he's doing this low energy
yeah he does a lot of he does a lot of
but you never see him do like he's
fast-paced as [ __ ] like he was his
energy
i stayed up at the top to watch him i'm
seeing him i was like he's i touch you
i'm like dude j pharrell's energy is
nuts yeah he comes out he also did you
see his biden
no okay because he did it towards the
end i think guys uh you left before this
but um
his biden is just accurate i've never
seen people do biden on snl but it's
like you're just kind of like they'll do
the jokes of like oh he's forgetful or
kind of like but he does biden's actual
voice
davidson's actual voice
like his his like i was closing my eyes
during his impressions and um oh yeah i
do that same [ __ ] with people that are
yeah he is with biden
seems like he's reaching for something
because he knows the words
the words are going to escape
and i think it was even better
he's refined it his kevin hart
impression is insane it's jay-z yeah
close your eyes for his character
accurate trump impression his trump's
good too his trump's good he's
inaccurate because i'm always like
typing this you can do like a caricature
of him and kind of like do it over the
top but he does he's he's he just has
i think people get it twisted because
they think he's just going to do
impressions the right time he works it
in but he has oh he works he has jokes
yeah yeah
like he was like yo what's up man i
better not have his cases
what you're talking about i'm sexy yeah
like do the top one yeah
because he's relaxed here all these
clips like
he
oh that's him as chris rock
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he has chris rock and eddie murphy i got
to hear his name kevin hart steve
harvey's mustache is legendary
[ __ ] talent man
[Laughter]
dude that's [ __ ] insane he's so
talented
yeah i stayed to watch him i've never
seen him stand up he's something yeah i
mean he was like
nonsense that's a very fast-paced energy
we should get him on here i know it'll
be so much [ __ ] fun y'all reach out
to him he's so good
um yeah i was just saying like
david spade
i'd seen him before i sounded to all new
jokes it was really cool to like um
and every like he tells real stories
like yeah you know like he just seems
like he's talking about like stuff
that's happened to him recently um it's
weird because you'll see some saturday
live guys like the old school alumni
go out there and they'll eat dick yeah i
think that's seeing quite a few when we
do like usually it's tough like they're
hard a lot of them don't do well no yeah
that's what's impressive about david
spade like his like he's been doing it
for yeah i'm always impressed with guys
that have been doing it for so [ __ ]
long yeah we could still go out there
and crush like they've been doing it for
decades and you know [ __ ] annihilate
he admits he goes like all these guys my
god he's standing for the art he's like
hey then you're in it for the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well i do it for the artist you know
when i was at juilliard he's such a
monster yeah
shouts out today
so that was a great night and then you
know
i got the call from you guys to come
fill in for brian today
and i turn on my car and i hear uh
on the prius
catalytic converter got stolen
oh the worst part of it all is my mom
when i when i was out in rhode island
visiting my brother and she's like mark
make sure as soon as you get home
get a protector for the catalytic
converter i've been reading a lot about
you know they're stealing them in los
angeles and do you think it's like oh
okay mom yeah that's never gonna happen
yeah someone jacked your brother on a
prius yeah
like yeah and i called up my brother
he's like it's not even worth anything
like from a prius like but i guess it is
actually an epidemic people are going
around i woke up or sorry i i turn
around i hear that and then i looked at
my windshield and like the cops had left
their card on there because i guess
somebody like must have seen it in the
middle of the night and called in oh it
was like hey call this to like report
you know yeah
it was actually in the uh no it was in
german oaks on the street so
um
you know [ __ ]
i guess that's the thing like if it's if
it's this in a line of cars or whatever
like there must be people who just go up
and down and like let's look under
that's their business three in the
morning yeah [ __ ] crazy though but so
were you able to drive here
yeah i put in the noise canceling
headphones it's just something i'm sorry
it's so loud it's so loud sounds like a
race car now
i mean it sounds like a loud
motorcycle yeah
like it's just are those things yeah
let's see are those parts expensive i
guess i think it'll be like 500 bucks to
replace it or something like that we go
okay who's stealing all the catalytic
converters four months ago
how long does it take a person to do it
right quick man
and how much are they getting for them
yeah like what
it was the middle of the day yeah broad
daylight i mean but if you're working on
a car you're not go up chin some guy had
a video up there with this one yeah
just holy
fat
catalytic converters
it's off the charts these days let's
find out why the worst part is admitting
my mom was right you know yeah yeah like
of all the things that they act
concerned about and like tell you like
you gotta go check this out make sure
you do this
[ __ ] yes you have to get it like she was
telling me to go get something welded
oh but she was showing on there jim
skipped it but it was showing on there
that priuses are like one of the number
one
oh okay so it is
did i say they're more valuable than
gold
and way up i'd be surprised if you don't
know somebody in your neighborhood
this guy
look at that toyo priuses 263 thefts i
became a overhaul so it seems like on
older cars
no the later pieces aren't new no no i'm
like well just like somewhat of an older
honda elements are new too
i don't i think it's wherever they can
get their hands on a catalytic converter
i mean so what are you gonna just drive
it around like that i'm gonna go take it
to the really [ __ ] yeah okay
[ __ ] because
no he can't do that oh god it's just
gonna annoy me yeah like two thousand
dollars like okay
yeah i talked to the guy he was like
if you bring it to the dealership it's
two thousand bucks but they like do it
you know with some other i don't know
what the difference is you don't do that
because they're the hours to for the
labor is so high a dealership yeah so
i'm not i mean i'm definitely not going
to pay you know insider warranty i
assume yeah how much is it worth it's
just
two thousand dollars well no that's
that's that's for his
it's saying the recent scrap price for
what year is yours
what year is that mark 2006
so
2006 yeah look at a thousand bucks for
that makes sense
jacking off your car
so it sounds like a [ __ ] old school
like yeah it's i mean i was i had noise
cancelling headphones and it was still
that loud oh yeah
damn now sometimes the engine shuts off
because it's like yeah you're driving it
it turns electric but um
as you're driving it it's like
couldn't you hit a mode where it's uh
all electric
after a certain point yeah but to
accelerate i think it uses the engine
pretty much always and you have to get
to a certain speed you got got i just
can't believe it you got guy you're
right your mom literally just what did
she tell you she was like you have to
put a cage on it or something like that
she was like oh like as soon as you told
you as soon as you got the car
yes
the roughest part is like she was 100 i
know right and i didn't know i mean like
i just i was like are you talking to but
i guess it is a prius yeah because
you're wrong like mom say a lot of [ __ ]
yeah to look out for you know exactly
okay there we go got to let it convert a
lock
leave it that seems like a lot of work
but you're going to need to get one of
those you're going to keep parking on
the street i know well yeah it's going
to happen again yeah oh for sure no i'm
definitely not going to like get it like
oh mark you didn't come back you didn't
think we'd come back
today's episode of final kid is brought
to you by athletic greens the health and
wellness company that makes
comprehensive daily nutrition really
simple man there's a lot of stresses in
life it's difficult to maintain
a diet and you don't know if you're
getting you know the right nutrients you
got busy schedules poor sleep your
exercise sucks just the environment the
work stress it's tough man it's tough to
step up your diet game but that's where
ag won by athletic greens gotcha covered
man we're talking about super food
product all right brings comprehensive
and convenient daily nutrition to
everybody all right to everybody one
tasty scoop of ag1 contains 75 vitamins
minerals whole food source ingredients
including multivitamin multi mineral
probiotics green superfood blend and so
much more in one freaking scoop i start
every morning with it one little scoop
and an eight ounce of water your boy is
ready to go so whatever you are man join
the athletes moms dads rookies first
timers comedians podcasters
crossfit peeps whatever it is maybe
you're doing the thick mudder and you
want a little extra boost get you ready
all right got you covered man all right
and to make it easy athletic greens is
gonna give you guys immune supporting
free one year supply of vitamin d and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit athleticgreens.com
fighter again all you got to do is go to
athletic greens.comfinder
to take control of your health and give
ag-1 a try
this episode of firing kid with mark
harlan chapelle lacy is brought to you
by the best supplements on the frickin
planet
that's right maybe getting ready for the
thick mudder january 29th thick mudder
we're almost all out of spots so if you
missed it you better go to
toughmudder.com right now look for the
15k
thick mudder with your boy run with the
squad chappelle lacey mark harley jay
shaw brian callum
freaking my brother-in-law steven's
doing it christian's doing it we casey's
doing it from the office the whole squad
will be there come hang out with us run
the race with us it's gonna be so much
fun we eat after it's gonna be a great
time but you're gonna need to uh be on
the right supplements man that's where
freaking on it comes into play here you
need to get your brain right we got
alpha brain you're you're in a bad mood
how about getting a great mood with new
mood what do you got you got digestive
problem total gut health there's not a
better supplement for your gut health on
the frickin planet we got krill oil
joint oil protein powder protein bites
protein bars we got streaming fitness if
you're trying to get in shape for the
thick mudder how about you do it at home
streaming fitness on your cell phone man
all right on demand workouts home
fitness programs kettlebells battle
ropes you got it all on it dot com slash
fighter 10 off i will see you january
29th at the tough mudder set up for the
thick mudder it's 10 a.m all right right
outside it's basically orange county all
right they say la it's orange county
that is the thick mudder january 29th
come run with your thick friends the
meet and greet we'll run together we'll
get it done but also get your best
supplements that you can for your body
on it.com 10 off
[Music]
so there is a breakthrough surgery where
a man needed a heart transplant and for
unknown medical reasons to us he did not
find a fit for him with another person
so they found a genetically modified
heart pig heart to put in him he a gmph
yes exactly uh he went through the
surgery successfully but now they're in
the waiting period to see if it sticks
if his body accepts it or not
he has a modified
big heart in his body yeah i saw this
yesterday this poor guy man yeah i would
have thoughts would call him like all
right goodness bad news good news found
your heart it's like oh my god it's
fantastic yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that
news is from a pig
and it's never worked on anybody else
but when you give it a go holy [ __ ] this
is is this the first of this uh i don't
know if this is the first of it but they
did say that this is the first time it's
been successful so far with like he
hasn't died yet
so
that is a success in of itself he says
my last choice yeah it was undergoing a
seven-hour surgery yeah might as well
give it a go
and uh pigs hearts are the same sizes of
ours it's genetically modified so i'm
not sure what they've done to it might
be bigger it might be a little smaller
they're actually similar size so that's
how they use the pick hearts
it said uh heart from a genetically
modified animal can work inside a human
body without immediate rejection jesus
christ i bet he goes vegan
100
um i would you guys see that show the
knickerbocker
um like it chronicles this guy who like
i guess revolutionized a lot of surgical
techniques at whatever you know i'm not
going gonna take a guess at how long ago
was it but like they show how somebody
would be in a car accident or something
or some sort of uh you know emergency
situation and they'd wheel you in and
they just practice on people who are
about to die like you don't even like
they'd be like all right we need to
search like you have to try this
technique right now um
what's the dude this character sounds
terrible it's called anchor blocker yeah
it was on hbo i think uh but the dude is
also like addicted to cocaine and [ __ ]
like that um and they're saying they're
trying to save the people yeah clive
owen was he played the doctor and so
because like how are you going to
practice these techniques except you
know like somebody's dying just like you
come in and like the main thing is like
when you cut somebody open like so much
blood is pouring out it's like you have
like 30 seconds to like you know stop
this bleeding um
interesting yes yes jesus knickerbocker
hospital it was really like a cinemax
baby but i think they played like was it
like the show doogie houser not at all
no it's super dark it's like it's like
the everything is like they open up and
they show them like probably not a high
success rate too because there's no only
one way to find out right you have to
like you're relying on people being
accidentally like they're gonna die
anyway
oh they're gonna die anyway like
somebody's bleeding out into a helmet
yeah so but like
you still have to you have to cut
somebody i mean think about modern
surgery like like you're cutting open a
body it's insane
without all these other things in place
that you're monitoring and techniques to
stop the bleeding and um
you know monitoring blood pressure
anesthesia all the you're also doing
anesthesia like you're just cutting into
somebody's stomach you know oh god
um
shouts out to that pig though we've come
a long way in other words there's a wild
rumor about drake this is insane do we
know if it's true we do what it's not
confirmed
right now also this makes you love drake
even more did you see his post on
instagram no the caption recent he said
he said something kind of like his drake
throws a lot of like sneak this under
yeah a lot of underlying like yeah his
recent post is something like it's
something like you can have your 15
minutes of fame i'll take the uh
right here
no i'll take the other 23 hours and 45
minutes so this rumor is that he hooked
up consensually with an instagram model
we do not know who the instagram model
is and after they finish having sex he
went to the restroom and try to dispose
of the condom and she later goes into
the restroom after he leaves she takes
it out of the trash can and tries to put
it into herself semen yeah his semen in
order to get pregnant but she suddenly
feels a burning sensation she starts
screaming he runs in says what's wrong
and she says
like
what's wrong
that he
allegedly put hot sauce into the condom
to kill sperm
dude like after the fact yeah i know for
sure i mean it's hard to get a girl
pregnant do we know for sure hot sauce
kills sperm i know it seems more like
people doing it
yeah smart i mean smart definitely have
to
have to
that is not drake would be out here raw
dog i love how she was like i'm gonna
assume it's like over what or what
you put the [ __ ] back in your body and
try to get pregnant yeah that was your
[ __ ] choice
oh all those are fake yeah as soon as
you type in hot sauce does hot sauce
kill sperm it's all drinking
[Laughter]
i've never heard of it before yeah i
have to assume it would it would be to
catch her like that yeah you know what i
mean like but jake just rolling around
with hot sauce like that yeah yeah
there's a lot of tick tock videos now of
people uh pretending to go to the club
and then putting hot sauce
um it's cool that he hasn't come out
tonight he's like even if it isn't true
he's just gonna let that little rumor
clean bear's a little weight concerned
sperm can only live for a max of 15 to
30 minutes outside the human body
yeah but if they just got done that
would be yeah and she goes right to the
right
to kill sperm is probably one of the
most ridiculous things i've ever heard
did everyone know hot sauce kill sperm
or did i miss the
that in sex education
you know google search engine exploit i
agree did we know if it works i don't
think so but hot sauce to catch the girl
yeah that does work now you know
you'd think a doctor would come out just
for their views on yeah say something
someone at this point will what'd you
say somebody will come out like i would
hope or make a video
and you also have to imagine that that
some portion of girls that he hooks up
with are going to do that yeah
you get a 100 yeah
he's a drake and he think about he had
it happened before with that stripper in
france yeah
cute kid so everything good thing came
in wait is that what she did
no oh i know that that's just
like getting pregnant you're not getting
rid of it like yeah she's yeah he's yeah
yeah she's like yeah i'm keeping drinks
baby yeah you're getting a payment every
month and you're sad chilling these hoes
are cute
cute kid
god he put [ __ ] hot sauce in it what
a legit
just have that rumors circulating what a
deterrent for any other girl in the
future
yeah
when i didn't think i could love him
anymore
he'll just be leaving the condoms and i
was like go ahead what a powerful
there might be hot sauce
yeah also how if this is all true how
did she not see that the [ __ ] condom
was orange or red yeah that's what i was
just thinking about i'm like wouldn't
you be able to get the hot sauce
i don't know yeah you better smell it
it's not the same color maybe you just
put like a little drip in you know yeah
just a little bit in that way yeah you
ever got hot sauce or like a pepper in
your eye yeah yeah
i did i
i was cooking steak and got [ __ ]
peppermint yeah it tastes like a
disaster oh imagine if she had had that
up to
oh so that's what you get that's what
you get
how'd you put hot sauce in your pee pee
hole right yeah same thing same [ __ ]
thing nightmare wash your hands drake's
a legend why not just
flush it i know you're not supposed to
flush it but why don't you just flush it
down he's testing these homes
i wouldn't risk testing having that girl
put my email you know i bet he's dealt
with this so many times he was like [ __ ]
this man make sure you leave and i'm
sure you told us handler make sure you
leave hot sauce in the bathroom for now
because hey we just flush it down we
don't know what we're dealing with b
if we if we do the hot sauce thing we're
going to realize she's a [ __ ]
scamming hoe yeah yeah it's a way to
test like you know you get to come back
for round two how awkward that must be i
know it's like because you think she'd
play cool face and she's all sweating
are you okay
yeah she should have just [ __ ]
straight faced him like nothing here
yeah
i'm gonna get going yeah right she
should have just let it go you i don't
think you'd be able to behave even if
you didn't acknowledge it and you acted
cool something would shift you know what
i mean like
sweating
and also i assume it would take you so
like even if you could piece together
what happened like you're just doing
that and then like your immediate
reaction you wouldn't think oh drake
must have put hot sauce in the condom
you know so you would have to like work
through like your immediate reaction
would probably be to scream yeah and
then realize what happened and then try
to be like oh nothing yeah in her
original post though she like gave out
like his uh like [ __ ] seven inches
girthy
the details of the post it was like
really allegedly drake had been sucking
on them titties before moving over to
the bathroom
we don't know who the model is
no
apparently this was a tip that was sent
in through dms on a anonymous like
gossip blog
very valid source
yeah
what a legend yeah
yeah the only thing suspect is yeah the
description yeah it was like yeah then
after done sucking on them titties but
she could make something happen if she
went got the condom and
dumped it in her it happens all the time
really yeah all the time
he had they put on he has a lyric about
it scroll down to him
and like girls girls will poke holes no
he talks about throwing uh magnums away
um
we're talking a girl that like gold
mellows flush the magnums just so
they're not collecting my specimens damn
he raps
specimens what a baller movement
specimen's all over her face
yeah you can't be mad at him for wanting
to do that
trying to protect himself
[ __ ] it yeah apparently she said he was
very up front like she was there for
like 10 minutes and he's like don't do
you want to have sex yeah she was like i
guess
why oh yeah time is money baby my house
you know if you're a drake though i mean
if you're it's like
i guess you could you know just be like
all right we're doing this or not 100
he's like i got [ __ ] to do yeah if
you're not down there's a hundred others
literally a hundred
within a block that's how he has to move
yeah yeah
are you down or should we just you want
to leave or yeah what have you got jen
what a legend though
he can't get over it so i mean insane
yeah i remember uh
just a quick thing about drake a friend
of mine's ex like
she was actually really like the really
hot light-skinned girl super obsessed
with drake went up to him at like a club
in hollywood like like a sushi place
whatever like katana or something
someplace nice
and
he was just she was so desperate to like
[ __ ] him and meet him whatever she went
up and was like whisper in his ear like
i'll have sex with you tonight and he
looks at her and goes get the [ __ ] away
from my table right now i'm gonna have
you removed
and like it got reported back to my
friend who would like i broke it up with
her because like she was with like that
would break down break your heart oh my
god
say you'll get the [ __ ] one
that makes sense though because
he's not trusting that and he's at
dinner too it was like she like
she was hot you know like super hot but
like for him though it's like right no
no
you don't realize it's like he's with
his friends he's probably like yeah yeah
he's plotting some [ __ ] and he was like
he was apparently he was like polite but
he's like
yeah but can you imagine that's your ex
and your buddies like did you hear what
[ __ ] mary did to drake yeah what
happened yeah apparently she saw him
yeah my sushi whisper in his ear i'll
[ __ ] you right now yeah shot her down
yeah i mean like mary did that
my marriage you're married dude [ __ ]
dragon got denied but that makes sense
for him to say say that to a girl like
that dude he's operating at such a high
level like for him to hook up with some
random crazy
it's just not worth it that's not real
because you're approaching like that and
he has a team that helps him out with
the filters these girls like yeah
there's all nba dude they move different
man yeah
what's this jeffy yeah it's like his
lawyer on site doesn't he yeah i'm sure
so two lapd officers were arrested
because
they ignored
yes this is like real
snorlax yeah two lapd officers ignored a
robbery in progress in order to go catch
a snorlax on pokemon go and if they're
quoted i just want to chase this
mystical creature yeah so they had
denied it because they they had a
conversation
whether they should go and figure out
what's happening with this robbery in
progress or to catch the snorlax and on
their body cam it filmed them having
this conversation of deciding not to go
to the robbery in progress they then
proceed to drive in the car for about 20
minutes around the block to get the
snorlax
the pokemon go
and this is why you don't want to defund
please like you want to put more
resources in so you don't have these
idiots playing pokemon this dude they
were probably trying to find your
catalytic converter
that's why they left their car that's
why they left
their car
he was like hey dude do you hear about
that cali converter he's like who cares
about it right dude we're so close cats
and snorlax
dude just put a card down let's throw
the guard down moving
we're on a dude hey
we'll get you next time though hey next
time dog we'll leave our card we're just
we got to stake him out and just see how
he moves and is it snorlax like tough to
find or what
on pokemon go i think it is but it's
it's the big fat pokemon that doesn't
move i don't know that was still dude
right like who still plays pokemon go
now how about how about this how about
the captions here uh
after uh mitchell apparently caught the
snorlax exclaiming got him uh uh
when the when their car stopped again uh
they record saying don't run away don't
run away while lanzo described how he
buried it in ultra ultra
bale bald
and then he said got him and then
mitchell the other cop goes still trying
to catch it holy crap man this thing is
fighting the crap out of me eventually
mitchell exclaimed holy crap finally
these guys can be so jealous
they then then they return to 7-eleven
uh and he said i got you a new pokemon
today dude
yeah wow
this is a snorlax this is what they're
trying to oh it sleeps right yeah it
sleeps all day and also who still plays
pokemon go that's what that's what i was
just saying i'm like i don't know anyone
that [ __ ]
yeah still [ __ ] like that 2016. yeah
scroll up chin
up
yeah because i love this what they put
here keep going so this is uh shout out
barstow who wrote this because here's
some context for those of you who have
had sex and aren't too familiar
i went ahead and did the research
according to bulba garden which seems to
be an authority on pokemon information
it was the first result on google these
are the two characters captured by the
officers mitchell lanzo lozano and
there's snorlax he's a big fat
he put it here best basically a cat it's
basically a cat it doesn't move
weird
and the update on your cadillac
converter dude i know right yeah lapd um
any updates on the
in the russian cast the siberian oh you
got him oh you did i got him nice how do
they look in person oh we we pick him up
valentine's day okay cool he's the only
cat's five weeks old and the others
12 or 14 weeks it's older he's bigger
yeah one of the cats looks like mark it
does have same hair long hair they have
long hair on the front yeah
short on the back and they're apparently
online they're they're only actual not
uh like the hyper allergenic cats yeah
like like straight up i was reading
their traditional
they have like a measurement of like the
amount of dander yes and that's why we
got them but i was i was telling kat and
i was telling brian this and chappelle
earlier on the i think on monday oh yeah
dude those cat breeders and dog breeders
are out of their [ __ ] mind dude they
don't want to sell us two two kittens
because my son's under five years old
yeah i was excuse me you sell cats yeah
they're very strategic are you judging
my lifestyle right these cats won the
[ __ ] lottery car yeah you know it's
worth it because i would assume now
i have had issues if you've never if a
kid has never like played with a cat you
have to teach them like you don't grab
the tail you don't but it's like it
takes two seconds two yeah my kids
here's what your kids yeah
you're gonna love it yeah it's not it's
not like that yeah it's not like i'm
saying i can understand where she's
coming from as far as like eliminating
all risk but all you have to do as a
parent is just sit him down and say this
is how you put the cat dude i have to
talk tell her like the the type of
person my kids are how good the kids are
send a picture of the kids yeah i was
like what the and then in my head i'm
like you [ __ ] idiot right what the
[ __ ] give us the [ __ ] cats how about
that they treat it and then you're like
and i was about my girl like why would
you tell me we have kids like [ __ ] them
they don't need this information then
also i went yeah hey mark
hey mark i'm gonna
say you don't have kids buy these
[ __ ] cats
drop them off at my house i was also
that i had it fired up i was going to be
like excuse me yes i'm a wealthy
homeowner
in tarzana i've owned it
they treat it like you're about to adopt
a child yes yeah now it's good that they
do some background screening but the
blanket rule of no kids doesn't make
sense to me because it's like you should
see the cheers
we never sell cats and they made an
exception for us so we got one kitten
and the one cat who's a tad older yeah
but but these cat the breed is really
well behaved i think that you guys are
gonna so they said they're like supposed
to be lap cats yeah they said they're
basically like dogs like they want
attention yeah poser you know most cats
are [ __ ] sociopaths they want to be
on their own and like yeah you know yeah
to actually get a cat to sit in your lap
is pretty rare because you're random you
must sleep with my kid why don't you
gotcha
the process was exhausting yeah
sue an influencer recently went online
and said that she found an air tag in
her bag after a night out and she found
out that someone actually dropped it in
her bag while she was i believe out at
dinner or a bar and as she was walking
just to track her yeah to track her and
figure out where she lived she posted it
online and a lot of people ended up
commenting that this is a new way for
people to track cars they put it on the
car yeah they
why does apple make traffic first of all
it's supposed to help track items like
your phone your wallet they have little
things like that your cat yeah some
people put it on their pets
and it's just uh hooked up to the find
my phone app so you can locate where
it's at
and this is how people are tracking put
this on my [ __ ] kids
it says uh so nader she's obviously a
baddie 830 000 instagram she's on uh
sports illustrated as well let's see
what really yeah
let's see if we drop a track because
those probably aren't they're not cheap
i assume so you can just try them you're
gonna you're gonna watch that at the
same time they're not the most expensive
thing yeah but this guy's gonna track
her to hopefully like run into her okay
she's a bonafide dime piece yeah okay
yeah because you're not just throwing
her you know you're not going to throw
some warlocks
yeah she's a bona fide baddie i get it
but also the guy what are you doing
she's also it looks like she's married
as well
so
but you can't trace that back to who
dropped it in
no your bag oh she's super because uh it
only hooks up to the device that you
registered it under and it's not her
phone so there's no way of her trying to
so she can get that information yeah it
doesn't work backwards that way i guess
yeah yeah
she's very pretty all you can do if you
find is throw it away damn
she's very pretty very pretty good for
good for the tracker i guess
up though you know yeah
i know now how'd she find it i wonder
how she found the track she said she
found it in her purse right uh she said
that she was notified that she had it
she doesn't specify what notified means
like if someone else found it yeah like
somewhere in her bag i have gotten a
random thing before it's like you just
passed by a tracker or something like
that like you ever got oh yeah yeah and
i was like i had no [ __ ] idea what it
was wait
you and i were together because you were
trying to airdrop me something but
something kept saying a hacker yeah
maybe that's how she found out
just after a while she checks her phone
and says there's a tracker nearby
yeah
weird
and then you can just put on your
vehicle and track you around there's a
lot of robberies happening in la too so
yeah
are they doing it you put on like a nice
car yeah yeah true like take it to
somebody's back yeah you put it on a
prius
steeler catalytic converter
but if you found it would you go get it
yeah of course
you roll up on him
yeah might as well chalk that up as a
loss
have you guys listened to the episode of
joy rogan and that
i guess he's like a doctor he got which
one kicked off of linkedin yeah yeah or
not yeah
for sure
no i think something like that you
probably did yeah you got kicked off
twitter for sure youtube yeah yeah yeah
youtube yeah what about them yeah dr
malone his name was i guess uh since
that episode came out and i would urge
every everyone to like listen to that
episode and yeah judge for yourself
right right uh since episode came out i
guess this over 200 something doctors
signed a petition to have put legal
uh penalties on joe rogan because of
misinformation now you realize this dr
malone created the
19 vaccination but what does that have
to do with jordan
well he gives him a platform because
he's the biggest platform in the world
yeah come on the show i just think it's
such a bad look because you're if your
goal is to censor this person guess
who's going to look him up after they
see that he's been taken off the
internet
everybody's gonna go out but it's also
like like you want to shut this doctor
down which fauci has done over and over
again people that don't agree with him
he tries to get them canceled like
notoriously known for that yeah but then
also with this it's like hold on you
want to cancel rogan this doctor because
they don't agree with what you're saying
but he's more qualified than you guys
are this doctor's more balls deep in
this cove [ __ ] than you are but because
it doesn't go with the narrative you're
pushing he shouldn't have a voice
right yeah and it's such a bad luck so
if you like
if you like that go to north korea dude
that's north korea that's russia yeah
that's not what we do here what you
should do or you know and here's the
thing rogan is happy like when people
disagree like with that that vegan
documentary came out the game changers
yeah one guy came and [ __ ] on it and he
had the other guy come on and yeah he
had to vote together have another doctor
on with dr malone exactly
like so the censorship thing just makes
it seem forbidden and bad and people are
going to seek it out and also
you know just strategically that's your
goal to shut this guy down and
de-legitimize him it has the opposite
effect that i think that's just human
nature like you're going to want to find
out like why why can't i why can't i see
this why can't why is this not supposed
to be absolutely i think i know but look
at the numbers compared to fox or cnn
he's you know they're like i think the
highest was like tucker carlson at like
two million or three million and rogan's
at an average of 11 million not even
close that's what they're trying to do
they're trying to they don't like that
rogan's this outline
destroys all of them combined yeah so
they're trying to censor that did you
guys you know the owner of spotify is a
swedish guy
in sweden they don't play these games
yeah they don't have this weird pronouns
and woken they don't play any of that
[ __ ] so he's not gonna do [ __ ] yeah is
there a company's worth billions of
dollars everything he does gets
immediately politicized and i've got to
correct so many people about rogan where
they'll be like oh he's isn't he all
right i had a conversation with somebody
recently a doctor
who uh
she was like oh like i mentioned joe
rogan who's like she goes you seriously
listen to joe rogan i'm like
yeah like what did you say what do you
listen to she has cnn like and that's
different so i didn't ask her what she
listened to but i broke it down and said
so here's some misconceptions you might
have first of all the people who listen
to joe rogan aren't listening to to just
get his opinion and follow everything he
says that's really not true he has
experts on he has a diverse range of
people from all over the world yeah
he'll have ben shapiro on and the next
he'll have bernie sanders on yeah and
it'll go on i like bernie sanders ideas
he just said
joe doesn't have an agenda like if you
watch cnn or fox there's an agenda
there's a plan a narrative that they're
pushing yeah joe's not and you would
think fox shane would pick up on this
clearly joe's so much more bigger
because it's an open-minded conversation
yeah there's no agenda so i always
listen to any of his guests even if you
know i have political disagreements with
them i'll listen and just go something's
going to come out of it and also joe
rogan is really good at like
in a long form like
conversation
he'll if you're full of [ __ ] you'll slip
up at some point oh yeah you know yeah
i'll get you
so it doesn't ask you to get to the
point right people think it's like oh
because it is in this like combative
thing the whole time it's like yeah he's
going to talk to you and talk to you and
find that point wait a second
well they they also can't stand that
he's this
quote unquote meathead comedian who's
also really smart educated on this stuff
that he can have these conversations
with these super successful doctors or
whatever these these freaking academics
and carry his own weight and they hate
that he doesn't commit to one side yeah
and yeah his numbers are shown to be
ideological well they want him they want
to push him far right yeah not even
that's so people so ever i've had this
conversation probably or they want to
push nor do they want to push oh he's
anti-vaxxed he's not yeah and i've had
this kind of a lot and it ends with what
it always ends with is i go have you
ever listened to an episode
and this is the doctor
she goes well and she was open-minded
enough like i i broke down the points
and i didn't get like anger or anything
i just said well the reason people
listen to him he's a good interviewer he
like is very curious he has people on
from all over you know different
opinions
also also he's not funded by pfizer like
cnn there's also that you [ __ ] [ __ ]
but it ends with oh i guess i've never
listened to an episode well then maybe
you should talk about oh i've been like
oh our conversation is over and you're a
doctor that was the end of the
conversation was like i go right she
goes well i guess i haven't i'm like
yeah thank you well it seemed like the
same thing people haven't it's the same
backlash on chappelle's special if you
ask anyone who's upset about it oh did
you watch it no i don't i don't need to
i just saw they just go
i hadn't watched it i just watched it
recently and my takeaway was actually
it should be celebrated as a pro lgbt
agrees he's advocating for it he's
taking people if you're already further
to the left than he is like you would
watch it and sort of try to police his
language but a lot of chappelle's
audience is probably
significantly less um trans accepting
than he is and he could move people a
notch
over here because he's talking about his
friendship with the transfer like all
these things it's like yeah talk about
friendship if you were anti-trans you
would watch that and probably move a
notch to agree and be more understanding
yeah
the backlash was weird but just the
topic of transgender sparks outrage yes
and so i just i was very i'm like i
wonder what like
really made people emotional watching
this but it's also like those emotions
and all those people upset and try to
cancel how'd that work out for you
how'd that work for you yeah
so passionate yeah exactly as far as a
strategy
and these these idiot doctors oh okay
the the do you sign some petition to
cancel rogan how'd that work out for you
i'll tell you how this ends for you guys
yeah not good did you guys cover the
ethan thing from the h3h3 podcast where
he's like joe rogan lives off hgh and
egg yolks and elk meat and he's talking
about because fat people got really
upset that he was like
you know saying hey like you don't get
to suddenly proclaim that you're super
health conscious i agree which is true
you don't get to decide like oh now my
health matters it's like well what how
old are you 30 yeah so for 29 years you
didn't give a [ __ ] about your health
yeah and now you're mr irwin yeah and so
don't work like that well yeah people
were this one guy
ethan i forget what his last name is but
you know ethan klein from what was it
h3h3 yeah yeah h3 he came out and had
this tweet and again even if you're just
looking at the strategy of like how do
you go about attacking joe rogan well
you know what he's doing it he's doing
it for the v he's just he's a click bait
guy yeah he's doing that right making
sense didn't have the frenemies thing
and then they had a falling out so yeah
all that it's the same thing with cnn or
fox like it's all click bait yeah so if
you mention rogue and like you even see
like on the mma side to be like rogue in
this or rogue in that they're not doing
it because they're anti-rogue and
they're doing it because you mentioned
rogan it gets clicked right that's the
same thing with this ethan kit the
attacks are interesting because
he does this interesting thing where
like people will be like he's injected
like he lives off of hgh and egg yolks
and that my first response is are those
things inherently unhealthy
my understanding is they're not like
taking
joe rogan has come out and said like i
take two iu's of wait that was his way
of attacking joe yeah he had this tweet
if you can maybe it's just an uneducated
it was like a list he's like this guy
lives off hgh and egg yolks and it's
like well egg yolks have like you know i
mean like fatty acids you know it's like
yeah it's a healthy thing that um
so he's attacking him like
you say i'm unhealthy
and then yeah here's the other thing too
he goes oh yeah because and brogan has
talked about this where it's like yeah
after i was eating like pasta all day
like i've had an extended belly from
overeating you know
a million times so does anybody
this was the tweet it's a different one
that was a different one yes um so your
children who likes to be on health is
pumped full of hormones this isn't the
one either uh if you look up h ethan
klein hgh egg yolks maybe then it says
ethan klein roasted by twitter after joe
rogan's tweets yeah it's it's
it's tough for a guy like that who lives
on out me okay super healthy egg yolk
super healthy hgh super healthy with
lungs full of tart smoking weed well
thinks he's healthier than everyone this
[ __ ] is such a [ __ ] that ooh he
would not say that to his face such
[ __ ] when you got cody threw the kids
together show healthy just right out
like you like you say a man should
what a terrible so that which implies
that he's not healthy joe rogan would
have been fine had he done nothing it
just would have taken a week right you
assume right you want to get over faster
you get back to a show yeah and then he
has the resources i don't understand why
why he would why this guy is doing this
oh just click bait but he's also he
probably gotta find because he's out of
shape he's not
right he's not in shape human beings
doesn't know who this guy is does he
absolutely not
okay are you [ __ ] me that's what i'm
saying i don't understand well no but
this again this is a popular trend you
see with anything like remember when
trump was trump with trump when trump
was president
if you want clicks you go hard at trump
you get clicks yeah trump's out we
really don't care so now who's the next
guy who's making moves rogan's this you
know pro choice pro you know pro like
taking care of your body not locking
down american first and so it's like
then they grab like that same hatred
idiot to gravitate towards him because
now that's gonna get clicks so for for a
youtuber it's like this is the take of
the day but the take was terrible yeah
now his take would be so much more valid
if he was in shape and healthy like if
that guy gets covered he's [ __ ] yeah
he's because you go you seem defensive
because you're fat but yeah why are you
defensive because for your entire life
you've never been disciplined enough to
take care of your body eat right and
work out because mention his name he
wasn't going like ethan he just said
like fat people and he's like [ __ ] you
joe rogan yeah but the thing is okay the
thing is like if you look at joe you me
rogan like you think i want to wake up
and work out every morning you don't
think i wish i could just wake up and be
in shape and be healthy
it's a discipline yeah it's a discipline
and one of the benefits of working out
eating healthy and taking care of your
body is if
randomly this [ __ ] disease gets
leaked from a lab in wuhan and it comes
to our [ __ ] nation
i'm gonna be okay yeah and that's one of
the benefits of being healthy yeah and
so now p these soy boys are like how
dare you yeah how do you i'm i take care
of my body no you don't yeah you know
i can look at i can look at your the
bags under your eyes dude yeah i'm like
your body it's not yeah you're [ __ ] i
think candace owen roasted megan mccain
for like
talking about um because i mean she's in
the category of like you're an
overweight person who's suddenly like
double masking and it's like
but you you don't really care about your
health outside of this dude suddenly you
became this yeah all of a sudden you're
mr whole foods okay that's that's what
they're saying like yeah people that are
like chicago
yeah like yeah they're hyper concerned
about this now
i would say this
you work out right
you mentioned
brendan mentioned me
the act of lifting weights or doing any
sort of stressful exercise like it's
just a i would consider just a stress
that you put your body through that
prepares it for other stresses yeah
you're more prepared to undergo stress
and um and yeah as you're saying brent
it's it's not fun and it's not something
that i'm always in the mood to do i love
it it takes a discipline yeah
and then that's one of the benefits if
heaven forbid a [ __ ] pandemic kids it
goes after the weak man it goes after
the old and they're really out of shape
that study just came out cnn posted cdc
came out said it 95
of the covet death people had four or
more [ __ ] underlying underlying
health conditions yeah four or more
are you [ __ ] me yeah so i and i
really didn't know you pointed this out
that like the um
when you go to the hospital it's like
broken leg oh but you test deposit for
covid whatever happens yeah yeah so
those numbers are and i don't know if
there's a bet like i don't proclaim to
know this system to know if there would
be a more effective or honest way but it
has been presented as something else
well cdc just came out and said and elon
musk when he was on rogan said this was
going to happen yeah he he called this
to a [ __ ] t like right when it hit
he's like here's what's gonna happen and
it's been interesting to see because
again over time you just see that uh
this is validating kind of these the
people who are shooting on brogan or
whatever had this take where it's like
shouldn't we be talking about health and
getting vitamin d and maybe exercising
and not shutting down gyms because
that's always still the most egregious
thing to me in the world is like we're
shutting down gyms yeah make you stay at
home you get fatter
it's just in the narrative that the talk
of being healthy not eating like a slob
isn't the narrative of this pandemic is
insane yeah didn't say it yeah like if
this doesn't scare you to get in shape
okay
yeah all right well if i don't know what
to tell you man yeah if the pandemic
didn't scare you to [ __ ] start taking
care of your body yeah just look at
people who are in shape you do pretty
well when you get covet yeah and it's
just the basic analogy i think is like
if somebody who hasn't ever worked out
where to do a workout like with the
exact same weights for example like you
might die doing something that i do in a
day because of the stress because with
the virus then we're not you're not
going oh well he's a little weaker give
him a smaller portion of the virus we're
getting the same thing so if you try to
bench 315 it might just fall on your
neck you know we're like
you know you see how
the same stimulus to two different
people who have been built up to you
know withstand resilience there's a
reason why this client kid
howard stern well you go after rogan
yeah you're like yeah the soy boy is all
the way over here and it's it's and i
saw that headline it's the popular thing
to do to go for logan because you can
get clicks from that side because that's
their enemy right now howard stern talk
[ __ ] about him
he talked [ __ ] and he talked about how
he talked [ __ ] about uh joke of it or uh
that that tennis player who didn't get
yeah but you know okay another thing
that i noticed because we're talking
about but notice all these guys who do
that are terrified of neurotic
terrifying that one trait is terrifying
this this pandemic really you see how
people who are neurotic and fearful like
talking about you know the comedian
they've always been like that though
right yeah but this this exacerbates it
yeah it's like oh you're really scared
and you will build your whole life like
how history probably doesn't leave his
house no no he sits in his high tower
when he was interviewing tracy morgan
because he was like tracy why you what
are you doing like there's a pandemic
going why are you leaving your house and
yeah tracy morgan's like well i'm going
to live my life right tracy morgan not
neurotic no yeah he's like i'm not going
to say i'm going to live but all those
similar people are terrified of the
world and soy boys now they actually
have a reason to gang together right and
go after you yeah no i'm not i don't
know
i'm smart you know i'm this is the right
way to yeah to live and and i've been
arguing with with people the whole time
everybody's just waving a flag going hey
giant [ __ ] lives here
it's crazy in some ways what you got
chin
all right um just a quick one on the
cover thing as well so you know aoc
she's a huge proponent like on falling
strict covet protocol she's in miami
without a mask yeah so of course she got
uh
she got the rona but then she was she
taught here
what'd you say was she did she did she
now here's here's the problem here is
she's been she's
super hard on lockdowns once mass she's
far left extremist to the max
yeah and then she doesn't
live by the rules that she wants to
impose on everybody yeah so she goes
[ __ ] it i'm go down to miami look at
this keep that same energy um
exactly all this is funny though because
i always would love people this is like
a lot of people ought to see this like
oh oh you're oh your mask and i have to
wash my hands and all this but then the
moment you want to do something you're
forgetting about it yeah
you know which i think the thing about
newsome at that restaurant knew someone
to shut down schools but his kids are in
a private school then he gets leaked and
he takes him out of school oh we didn't
feel safe so we took him out no [ __ ]
you don't feel safe because you got
caught
you want to enforce these rules on
everybody but you don't want to live by
because you know they're awful yeah
nancy pelosi too remember she went to
this got a haircut in san francisco
was it wearing a mask bited inside the
convenience store no mask it was
interesting everybody
seemingly i don't know how long it's
going to take before you realize no
matter left right all these politicians
are [ __ ] scumbags they're all pieces
of [ __ ] in order to be a politician you
got to be a piece of [ __ ]
but you got to do some weird dark [ __ ]
yeah then also you got to be the biggest
narcissist in the world think that you
can make a change you know what i'm
saying yeah and then when they do get
power you give them a [ __ ] inch
they're going to take a mile oh you knew
some yeah look at all these [ __ ]
crazies out there yeah it's exemplified
by the people that's on both sides both
of them are [ __ ] crazy yeah i don't
like any of them you uh you believe
you're above the law sort of like one of
these basic traits of narcissism like
you don't think the rules apply to you
yeah you're setting the rules and then
you don't think there are that's why no
one [ __ ] with uh kamala harris nobody
[ __ ] with you know new some because
there's this weird arrogance where
they're like do what i say don't do what
i do wait did you see when she was asked
what her biggest accomplishment was
kablaharis
oh it was awkward her biggest
accomplishment bro if she said i've been
kind of watching a lot of like kamala
harris cringe i can't i can't lately
because like
there was a point like she she looked
impressive when she was like grilling on
the debate she got lit up no this was
before remember like people got hot
about her because
i think she maybe it was like um
it was like gorsuch or something like
one of these guys as a senator she was
really one of the supreme court nominees
and she's like good at the lawyerly
stuff when she's really prepared but
everything else
outside of that horrible
yeah and she's so obvious
or her likability like i don't know yeah
i i don't know and i have friends who
are far left middle right i don't know
anybody who [ __ ] with i remember going
a cardio kickboxing class even though
she tries so hard to get like the black
i never hear anything about her
but also i don't know she's just
watching this because she's my choice
too she's trying to get out of the
limelight because they know she will
[ __ ] up like like she'll be in a room
she's so unlikable she's a she's a bad
politician yeah she's not charming you
know i guess that's not my favorite
movies because i don't watch i don't
watch any of that you don't need to just
take it
so she's trying to avoid major gaps
because they've realized that she's um
she's just unlikeable she's there's her
communication skills suffering
the kamala's saying no did you see her
once you want to visit the kids
like oh but it's next eight-year-olds
even though i don't know
like eight-year-olds are like oh i'm all
set dude she's like you can be an
astronaut wouldn't that be fun the kids
one is good and then also if you say
what's your best what's your biggest
accomplishment i think was sort of
recent
um
there we go
her response is hilarious
uh
so is your video please let me know
that the video
this is for the kids the kids okay
she's a pretty lady too man you've never
discovered yet to think about so much
these kids are paid actors by the way
they're paid actors
she just comes off so fake
about the space council we're gonna
learn so much we're gonna learn so much
as i think we are increasingly curious
with the discoveries so and the space
i'm most excited about
but the other
you guys are gonna see
you're gonna literally see the craters
on the moon with your
oh yeah these are these are they got
paid kids they're pretending to be there
wait what was their answer
yeah video so she says in terms of work
some videos i think to
i mean it's so wide-ranging it's
everything from again what we talked
about maternal health i love electric
vehicles i love electric vehicles i
remember she pivots right there she's
like what's my biggest accomplishment i
meant uh electric vehicles i love of
course i'm going to be like when it
comes to that stuff she goes again 25
million children at least pre-covered a
day in america go to school in america
on these diesel trucks these buses and
inhaling these fumes which have direct
impacts on their ability to learn this
is her answer to what's giving us a
lead pipes
the space council i'm very excited about
that work because it's not only about
stem it's also about natural serious
about international norms so there's a
variety of work and diverse in terms of
writing just literally i'm sure the
interviewer was like what the article
says if you were looking for
accomplishments
in that wide-ranging answer good luck
nothing yeah jesus christ what else you
got jen oh man i wish i could find the
video
the one with the kids it's just yeah
just look up there i'm saying regardless
they were there they shot that we're
like let's hear this right because it
wasn't live yeah you think like who's
approving this [ __ ] you think they'd be
like let's hold off on this but yeah so
but like it's funny because when you
here it is like
what you actually see is your biggest
accomplishment
well
that's a great question
no you already know she's [ __ ] right
there i love
electric vehicles i'm like
what does that have to do with your
accomplishments
space council i'm very excited about
that work and these are her
accomplishments
she's panicking right now
again how does white house go hey can we
cut that can we just
i don't the white house has so much
power how are they it's like they're
like there's nothing we can do dude like
anytime she talks it ruins
what a combination how do they not just
how does the white house just not flex
i'm like you can't that last part we
asked for accomplishments edit that yeah
well that's like me answering that
[ __ ] question
i was like
um
especially at her level
they don't that's not like a random
question there's there's a rundown like
when marc maron interviewed uh obama
yeah it wasn't like freestyle go with
the flip yeah he had them they list oh
yeah they have a lot and also you would
you wouldn't think even if you had to
anticipate that wouldn't be a top five
thing you'd go like they're probably
going to ask you what your biggest
accomplishment is like you go to a job
interview what is your greatest strength
what's your favorite that's that
that's a fair question yeah
even at the white house when they do the
open thing with the
head lady you know the redhead who's a
beast yeah like she kind of know like
when she picks she knows exactly what
the person you say and then they know
she's gonna get some [ __ ] from the fox
guy yeah she knows exactly yeah like all
that yeah and she's just they control
everybody who does that job you got to
be [ __ ] just
ready it's not that i it's not that i
disagree or agree with her but she has a
tough job dude and she's
she's a savage with it yeah should be
like like she knows like a way to
navigate around the questions yeah
excuse me you don't think i covered that
earlier did you not hear me earlier like
right who's who's this
she's a beast yeah like i would not want
her job it's so hostile and you can tell
like she gets i bet she's in the back
[ __ ] shut up
she's getting ready
yeah that's a tough job
and maybe she should uh
coach kamala up a little bit but
apparently she's just terrible when
she's unprepared and as you saw i mean i
don't know why you wouldn't be prepared
for like for a fair that's that's kind
of a universal question yeah i don't
think that's a gotcha question yeah that
doesn't like pin you into against the
wall again it's not a left or right
thing with her it's just like nobody
like even people close in like her
workspace have quit yeah i guess she's a
nightmare correct oh really yeah the the
rumor is that her staff is fleeing
because they need to see it as a sinking
ship if biden doesn't run again
kamal is not a better answer you know
you're looking at democratic strategy
like you would say like all right let's
throw them yeah they're pulling the cord
now that this ain't it yeah um because
some people were just like
he's not able to run in 2024.
kamala harris isn't the step up i mean
she couldn't even win california you
know but again it's a testament to i
remember i was taking this card to
kickboxing class and heard some of these
wine moms like oh you know what i like
it's just you know i remember actually
they're dissing bernie say like i am so
sick of bernie sanders you know who i
like kamala harris like but they just
like the fact that she's hot and sort of
like she's like she's very pretty yeah
like she's got like out of
uh you know
she shows how awkward she is in that
scenario but like yeah she's sort of
like can pull off looking cool sometimes
but with the timberlands you talk to a
black person who knows who's in the know
and they're like oh yeah you mean when
you try to like put my brother in jail
for smoking yeah like yeah or put them
away for 20 years selling weed or
there's another thing um
this this mom i knew who like
she uh she had some issues with
homelessness and and her kid like she
had to take her kid out of school and
they're like she was trying to punish me
like put me in prison or make it like a
criminal penalty for like
my kids truancy yeah it was like because
of you know what i mean like
black people do not like california
because of the policies that she
promoted what else you got jen let's see
a will compton thing yeah just real
quick cause uh i follow him on instagram
as well he's your boy uh he's been going
through some tough times i guess mother
just mom passed away which is really
tough so he had to miss some games i
believe
uh so he played for a little while with
the raiders got cut but then the next
day they signed him again because
someone uh got the coveted or something
like sure so he played and then he got
cut again what though because they're
retooling their you know their team for
the playoffs so is he not on the playoff
team no not anymore
but they they said some really nice
words i think posted on his instagram as
well i love will yeah and we're supposed
to do a
super ball campaign me will
he put faces on this but
that's right he's hilarious
i'd like to say something can i say
something absolutely
you know these two guys that are sitting
up here they're not defined by one game
these guys played great for us all year
they're great competitors they were
great leaders on this team uh and they
could they contributed tremendously to
the success of this team and we would
not be here without them all right both
of them contributed in a lot of ways in
a positive way to given us a chance to
win and the chance to be here to have an
opportunity to win so i just want to
thank them for that and let everybody
know how proud i am of those
never mind
i just reading the signs right now
thank you very much
and well
thanks for your time we'll let you head
back to your locker room and how do you
know will brennan
is it will does the show
on barstool oh i've just me and him i've
always [ __ ] with each other yeah he's
always even before he's with barstool
yeah he's such a good dude
i whenever i'm in nashville he's doing
his show he does a show with uh taylor
lewin uh who's the pro ball like
probably hall of famer left tackle uh
for the tennessee titans so he's played
for the titans yeah taylor's like
i mean one of the best to ever do yeah
so he'll go the hall of fame and then
will is a linebacker for uh the
at the time for the titans nice but they
do a podcast together and they're cool
yeah they're great
the thing that's gonna [ __ ] up that
super bowl companion is if the titans
are in the super bowl so i'm kind of
rooting for him to lose but i also love
taylor i want to be a super bowl ring
i also want to lose so we do the show
yes
and it looks like it was gonna be free
for the show and is it just gonna be
youtube
no we're gonna have no be will taylor
and then we're gonna have one more guy
okay cool
what else you got you all right well for
that video i guess it says
something young and some other two other
names so i'm not sure exactly what that
video is oh that's from the alabama game
that's bryce young the heisman
quarterback who lost and the other i
think is the receiver for the team got
you
um last one
let me see here well let's we already
talked about the tennis player
let's go with this i think this is a
so it's a little bit more details about
bob saget um so he was found sleeping
right now so so far it takes like 13 or
whatever days to get like the toxicology
it takes
yeah maybe i think maybe
but he said he was sleeping with like
one arm on the bed and one arm or one
arm on his chest and he was face up
piece yeah peacefully and then he had
like a great night
storytelling was amazing that night so
it seems like you know if you're going
to go that's the way to go yeah wow
yeah yeah
that's such a bummer
um shout out to bob saget you guys have
met him before oh yeah i know i never
met him just seen him in passing
monster is that it jim that's it that's
it all right kids uh a few housekeeping
notes i will be at levity live with
chris delia and crew
and oxnard california friday and
saturday i'm there featuring for chris
and then i'm doing shows around l.a like
last time the store the improv i'm sure
i'll be
all around la like i told you i'm taking
all of january off from touring outside
of california but uh next date would be
hollywood improv shop and friends
january 26th that [ __ ] will sell out so
if you didn't get tickets the last two
shows come on out last special guest
crystalia we've got theo on there so
we're gonna have some monsters we have
another monster special guest that's the
26 26th of january 8 pm wednesday one
show only
outside that sacramento california
punchline sacramento february 24th
through february 26th chicago i'm there
march 24th through march 26th that's
chicago
illinois
tickets at fatkz.com also if you haven't
uh subscribed yet to the thick boy super
cast where you get ad-free uh shows
every show i do there's two tears the
first tear which is the thick boy uh
package for five dollars you get the
shop show food truck diaries calabasas
uh fight companion the ama the bonus
classic cowbest fight companion this
week we have sugar shawn me and him are
sitting down watching his fights that's
all on thickboy.supercast.com
uh we're also adding some new stuff to
that which i'll announce next week the
second tip for eight dollars you get all
that plus fighting the kid twice a week
and uh for the ad-free video uh the link
will be in the description box of the
audio to get your
dashboard access videos so if you're
having any issues if you're not finding
the video the the link is in the
description box on the audio all right
that's how you get the ad free video so
that is
uh
thickboy.supercast.com that bad [ __ ] is
rolling i love you guys for that boom uh
kansas city i'll see you febru february
25th and 26th at the comedy club of
kansas city uh support my merch support
my podcast chappelle's world all that
stuff chapelle is where you can find out
thick boy if i don't watch it on thick
boy audio stays the same we get a lot of
love thank you guys for that by the way
with uh with the podcast mark haters
will say it's coming on over to thick
boy as well but the audio stays exactly
the same haters will say baby like
subscribe
every tuesday at 3 p.m talk about
fitness i give you recipe ideas um
yeah just a general good time
yeah it's entertaining i don't know it's
like fitness and he might take your
shirt off and [ __ ] gets crazy and wild
sometimes a chance he takes his shirt
off you never know what's gonna happen
really and david lucas show where he
roasts people it's called flat line with
david lucas that's coming to the thick
boy channel as well next week and we're
shooting our first one today so if you
want to get roasted by david lucas
follow david for information on that but
it's going to be a hot i don't know 10
12 minutes of david lightnings [ __ ]
people
it's the best it's the i got the idea
what i got the idea we're uh driving
into uh the comedy store in la jolla and
he's on instagram live yeah and people
are just getting on his life and he's
just lighting them up one by one he'll
do it he takes on anybody yeah i was
like and people like to do this like
they love getting roasts i'm like that's
a show dude yeah now it's the show it's
called uh flatline with david lucas yeah
you'll see it on think boy youtube only
shout david lucas shout out all right
kids love ya be safe brian good luck
with that little baby bambino and uh
take care guys see you next week bye